[Musique]
oh
génomique au junior est acteur auteur
compositeur et interprète 1997 il a
quitté son winnipeg natale pour réaliser
son rêve de jouer dans des comédies
musicales
c'était pas mon rêve d'être une star
mais c'était c'est beaucoup de chance
que j'arrivais ici avec son rôle
principal dans footloose en poche tout
destin le conduit alors à new york dans
la mecque des comédies musicales
j'ai le méco chineurs n'a pas chômé
depuis son arrivée ici jusqu'au
lancement d'une nouvelle comédie qui n'a
pas eu lieu à cause de la pandémie
car depuis trois mois tout s'est arrêté
ici
yet aînés vedette la pandémie n'a
épargné personne dans l'industrie
bon
joe cada qui travaille depuis 17 ans
comme personnel de salle dans un théâtre
de broadway acteur à ses heures il
vivote dans l'industrie qui représente
son rêve américain
[Musique]
des spectacles
il en a vu une centaine sont préférés la
bohème un titre qu'il vit pleinement
depuis dix ans dans son logement de 8
mètres carrés
mais aujourd'hui avec le chômage il peut
à peine payer son loyer de tenez vous
bien
1200 dollars américains
sans aucune date de réouverture avant de
nombreux mois bredou et souffre loin des
projecteurs
[Musique]
quant à une reprise à court terme avec
une distanciation physique
12 nov
[Musique]
ça c'est vraiment vraiment difficile
avec le recul les artisans de
l'industrie du divertissement new
yorkais ne changerait rien à leur choix
pour l'instant est filmé en intégrant
d'autres restent réalistes car les
débouchés ici et ailleurs à moyen terme
sont plutôt limitées mais comme broadway
vend du rêve
il n'y a rien pour décourager jeribi
kouchner qui a déjà hâte à la prochaine
réouverture
peu importe quand
mua
nous
oh
comme on dit ici de show must go on le
spectacle doit